do you want to understand your favorite
disney movies well this lesson is based
on the themes
and characters of one of pixar's best
movies wally
it has no spoilers so don't worry if you
haven't seen it
and if one of your goals is to
understand all the jokes
and not get lost even without subtitles
then you are in luck because you found
the youtube channel
that will help you to achieve this goal
like in hiki
who says that he can understand 90
percent after our lessons
so hit that subscribe button and the
bell down below so that we can help you
with new lessons every single week
now let me tell you how this lesson is
structured
so first andrea and i will introduce you
to the story of the movie
by talking about the setting main
character and theme
then as we do that you'll learn some
vocabulary related to the story of the
movie
and then we will have a chat about this
beautiful movie
involving this cute little robot named
wally
[Music]
it's the year 2805 and there are no
human beings left on earth
some seven centuries ago a corporation
called by and large assumed control of
the planet's entire economy
and government and humanity got into a
vicious cycle of buying more things than
when needed
and producing mountains of trash that
covered the entire planet
so wally is our cute little solitary
robot that is in charge of cleaning
all the garbage off the surface of
planet earth
in the year 2105 all humans took off to
space
because earth was full of waste and at
this time
there were millions of other similar
robots assigned with the same task
but when the plan to restore the planet
failed all robots but this one were
turned off
so wally has been cleaning up earth for
700 years
so he feels quite lonely and nostalgic
we know that this story is about a robot
in a futuristic setting on earth
then he meets eve another more
sophisticated
robot and then they get entangled in a
little romantic story
later they go on a mission to bring
humanity back to earth
however the theme of the movie is more
than just a description of the events
that happen
the theme is the message within the
narrative
the movie has strong underlying themes
which ethan and i will talk about in a
moment
in my opinion a few themes this movie
incorporates
are consumerism nostalgia and
environmental issues
now we'll focus on a vocabulary set
that's related to the story of this
movie
waste waste is unwanted materials or
substances
that are left after you have used
something example
the city is trying to recycle a third of
the waste it produces
when you see this movie you'll see that
cities have turned into
wasteland which means an unattractive
area often with old ruined buildings
factories etc in it then there's waste
material such as paper
or empty containers or food that you can
throw away
now in the uk they call this rubbish
while in the u.s we say
trash or garbage instead a common
collocation we use to describe an
everyday action
is take out the trash or take out the
rubbish
in the movie wally's job is to clean up
all the waste that humankind has left
behind
so he has to literally pick up all the
dirt and useless objects
and put it somewhere where he collects
the trash
now before we move on to our
conversation here's some more useful
vocabulary
try to match these five words with the
five definitions
bleak pile lonely
seedling filth
[Music]
a group of several things of the same
type that are put on top of each other
[Music]
dirt dirty stuff
unhappy because you have no one to talk
to
unhappy unpleasant having no hope
[Music]
a young plant or tree grown from a seed
by the way are you ever confused because
you're not sure what vocabulary to
prioritize learning
and how to actually remember it well a
great way to learn the vocabulary
that you actually need in real life and
have a lot of fun doing it
is with our fluent with friends course
now this course will take you on a
journey with friends
the best tv series for learning english
while learning
and remembering thousands of the words
and expressions
that you really need so that you can
confidently understand natives and
communicate
the best part you can try it for free
with our three-part
master class so sign up now by hitting
up here
or down in the description box below
all right andrea what's next in our
conversation coming up
you'll see that all the vocabulary
you've learned up to this point is going
to be highlighted in yellow
the words you'll learn after watching
the conversation
will be in blue
so ethan the whole idea for this movie
started as a question
what if mankind evacuated earth and
forgot to turn
off the last remaining robot yeah that's
interesting
to add to what i said in the intro this
company that governed earth sent
everybody on an intergalactic five-year
cruise so that these many
wally type robots could clean up all of
the piles of waste
and trash left on earth when that plan
didn't come to fruition
as we said they turned off all the
robots except for the one that we see in
the movie
yeah so ultimately earth was considered
too toxic to support
life again it's really sad and
we see wally is quite lonely because
there's no one he can play with
well there's a cockroach actually
yeah he finds a good friend in that
cockroach we mentioned a
few themes that this movie deals with
yes the first one that i noticed was
consumerism
humanity got into this vicious cycle of
consuming and consuming
the waste and rubbish started to pile up
so much that they ended up having to
evacuate the
whole planet yeah what's scary about
that is that in the movie
that happens in 2105 that's less than
100 years from now
but we already are pretty
consumer-oriented species
are we doomed to that bleak future i
really hope not
the other theme that we mentioned is
issues having to do with the environment
i read that's a strong theme in the
movie obviously the movie shows us what
it looks like in the aftermath of an
environmental catastrophe
the other theme you mentioned is
nostalgia so
wally keeps a collection of objects that
remind him of how the world used to be
in the past so he keeps a rubik's cube
a light bulb a match lighter and there's
also the song that he plays when he goes
about the land cleaning all the filth
oh and i thought that a really happy
moment was when he found a seedling
that brought hope yeah it also
emphasized this feeling of nostalgia
again like something so simple as a
seedling made him reminisce about the
time
when there used to be so much life and
the world was so colorful
what if mankind evacuated earth and
forgot to turn
off the last remaining robot mankind
or humankind are terms that refer to all
humans considered as a group
example the discovery of fire was one of
the most
important events in the history of
mankind
this company that governed earth sent
everybody on intergalactic
five-year cruise so that these many
wally type robots could clean up all of
the piles of waste and trash left on
earth
a cruise is a holiday on a large ship
notice that to say this the vowel is a
long
u sound and the last consonant is a
z sound cruise while traditionally we
think of
ships when we say cruz you could use
this word to mean a cruise on a
spaceship
when that plan didn't come to fruition
as we said they turned off all the
robots
except for the one that we see in the
movie if a plan or idea comes to
fruition
it begins to happen exist or be
successful
example the entrepreneur's idea never
came to fruition
this also collocates with bring example
she worked very hard to bring her dreams
to fruition
they turned off all the robots except
for the one that we see in the movie
notice now that my pronunciation on this
wasn't
they turned off all the robots rather
i linked some of these words to make my
speech flow better
they turned off all the robots yeah so
ultimately
earth was considered too toxic to
support life again
earth was toxic because it contained
poisonous substances
this is because the wally robots were
supposed to burn the waste that they
accumulated
and this is what created the toxic
emissions that made earth unsuitable for
life
if a planet isn't suitable for life or
it can't support life
it means that it doesn't have the
conditions necessary for living things
to exist there
for example mercury can't support life
because it is too close to the sun
it's really sad and we see wally is
quite lonely because there's no one he
can play with
well there's a cockroach actually a
cockroach is this insect
in the first half of the movie we see
wally becomes friends and interacts with
this cockroach which he names hal
yes the first one that i noticed was
consumerism
consumerism is the belief that it is
good to buy
and use a lot of goods and services
andrea described the effect that
consumerism had in humanity
saying that humans got into a vicious
cycle
of consuming too much humanity got into
this vicious cycle
of consuming and consuming what she
meant by that
is that often buying things makes you
want to buy even more things
this is what ended up ruining the planet
because humans were producing too much
waste
are we doomed to that bleak future we
use the word doom
to refer to a very unpleasant future if
we say someone is doomed to something
we mean that they're probably going to
experience that
unfortunate future example if i don't
study more i'm doomed to fail this
subject
you already saw that bleak means sad and
unpleasant
this word is very often collocated with
future
example the company has a bleak future
to express the opposite you could say
for example
the company has a bright future
obviously the movie shows us what it
looks like in the aftermath of an
environmental catastrophe
the aftermath is the period of time
after something such as a war
storm or accident when people are still
dealing with the results
example one aspect of the aftermath
of covid was that a lot of people lost
their jobs
the other theme you mentioned is
nostalgia so
wally keeps a collection of objects that
remind him of how the world used to be
in the past let's now take another look
at the use of connected speech
in this conversation first notice how i
left out the
h in him and connected with the previous
word as
remind him this also even links with
of remind him of there's more linking
in this part remind him of how the world
used to be in the past
i'll say it two more times with a pause
in between for you to practice
remind him of how the world used to be
in the past
[Music]
something so simple as a seedling made
him reminisce about the time
when there used to be so much life and
the world was so colorful
if you reminisce about something you
talk or think about pleasant events
in your past example when i see my
ex-classmates we always reminisce about
the college days
colourful literally means full of colour
this is in contrast to the bleak mainly
grey-coloured landscape we see in the
movie
if you've enjoyed this lesson you can
catch all of our lessons with your
favorite disney movies in this playlist
just click up here or down the
description box below and watch that
after you finish the test
[Music]
so ethan the whole idea for this movie
started as a question
what if mankind evacuated earth and
forgot to turn off the last remaining
robot
yeah that's interesting to add to what i
said in the intro
this company that governed earth sent
everybody on an intergalactic
five-year cruise so that these many
wally-type robots could clean up all of
the piles of waste and trash left on
earth
when that plan didn't come to fruition
as we said they turned off all the
robots
except for the one that we see in the
[Music]
movie
yeah so ultimately earth was considered
too toxic
to support life again it's really sad
and we see wally is quite lonely because
there's no one he can play with
well there's a cockroach actually
yeah he finds a good friend in that
cockroach we mentioned
a few themes that this movie deals with
yes the first one that i noticed was
consumerism
humanity got into this vicious cycle of
consuming and consuming
the waste and rubbish started to pile up
so much that they ended up having to
evacuate the whole planet
yeah what's scary about that is that in
the movie that happens
in 2105 that's less than 100 years from
now
but we already are pretty
consumer-oriented species
are we doomed to that bleak future i
really
hope not the other theme that we
mentioned
is issues having to do with the
environment i read that's a strong theme
in the movie
obviously the movie shows us what it
looks like in the aftermath of an
environmental catastrophe
the other thing you mentioned is
[Music]
nostalgia
so wally keeps a collection of objects
that remind him of how the world used to
be
in the past so he keeps a rubik's cube
a light bulb a match lighter and there's
also the song that he plays when he goes
about the land cleaning all the filth
oh and i thought that a really happy
moment was when he found
a seedling that brought hope yeah it
also emphasized this feeling of
nostalgia
again like something so simple as a
seedling made him reminisce about the
time
when there used to be so much life and
the world was so colorful
so first let's take a look at where and
in what time the novel unfolds
the hunger games is a novel that unfolds
in panem
an apocalyptic world sometime in the
future
geographically panum is located in north
america
but characters in the story mention
large areas of land across the world
that have become
uninhabitable due to rising sea levels